[Musik]
thomas vinterbergs film kurs ist
eigentlich eine ziemlich konventionelle
kinoproduktion es geht um die kunst das
heißt es gibt vorteile und nachteile bei
diesem modell zu den nachteilen gehört
beispielsweise dass in dieser
transeuropäischen großproduktion über
den unfall die havarie eines russischen
atom u boots von 19 jahren praktisch
keine russen zu sehen sind
stattdessen treffen wir eine menge
deutsche schauspieler peter simonischek
sagt matthias schweighöfer augustin
unter den mitgliedern der crew oder im
fall von simonischek sogar als
russischen flotten admiral
erinnern sie sich an die kundschaft ein
erstes kommando
jetzt keine raketen werden wird sondern
liefert fleisch und gemüse an unsere
basis in politik und dazu ebenso viele
schauspieler aus frankreich oder belgien
nicht zuletzt den belgier matthias
schönheits als u boot kommandanten der
hier eine der großen leistungen seines
lebens abliefert
[Applaus]
zu den vorteilen gehört dass es bei
dieser art von projekt gewisse standards
gibt auf die man sich verlassen kann
dazu gehört zum beispiel die technische
abwicklung dieses u boot untergangs dazu
gehört aber auch die besetzung neben dem
bereits erwähnten schön arzt vor allen
dingen max von sydow in der rolle des
russischen präsidenten der in
wirklichkeit damals wladimir putin hieß
hier aber wird er von sido als ein
relikt des kalten krieges gespielt wie
es eindrucksvoller verkürzter felsiger
verhärteter nicht sein könnte sie den
vorteilen dieser art von produktionen
gehört auch dass der kameramann anthony
dort mental eine der wirklichen
virtuosen seines fachs ist er hat schon
mit winterberg bei dessen debüt das fest
zusammen gearbeitet mit dem damals die
doppler welle in den europäischen kinos
kam
es gelingt ihm die rigorosität die
energie mit der er damals schon
gearbeitet hat auch hier in diese
gattung zu übertragen und dort mental
schafft in diesem versinkenden u-boot
körper tief unter der meeresoberfläche
tatsächlich raum wirkungen die man
dieser art von film nicht erwartet hätte
tiefen ein spiel von von dunkel und hell
von verlorenheit und hoffnungen was
optisch ganz aufregend akzentuiert ist
und es gelingt ihm auch an land bilder
zu machen von einer landschaft die
geradezu auf das unheil zu warten
scheint an der landschaft kann man sagen
in der dieser verfall der russischen
flotte quasi schon eingeschrieben ist
mit anderen worten dieser film erzählt
nichts völlig neues der fall der kurs
geht er ohnehin durch die nachrichten
gelaufen aber in einer gattung in einem
genre in dem es schon viele große
untergänge und katastrophen gegeben hat
schafft er doch eine kleine nuance einen
fortschritt in der darstellung den mann
nicht ganz unterschätzen sollte ein
konventioneller film aber auch ein
interessanter
[Musik]
aber ich hätte gern noch mehr gegeben
und beiden du bist meine ewigkeit
[Musik]